and it very much reminds me of something
that you've said many times which is
that when you had been working in
television before you started writing
the books you were so frustrated by how
you couldn't get sort of scale the
grandeur and scale that you wanted and
and you knew that in fiction you could
just do whatever you want to make it as
big as you want and and this is really
big and really impressive can you talk a
little bit about you know what what
inspired this particular idea the idea
of the wall well it was Hadrian's Wall
actually in in in 1981 ten years before
I even dreamed of writing his books I
visited England for the first time and
my friend Lisa shuttle with whom I've
collaborated on when David was driving
her me around England at Scotland and
showing me the sights and we came to
Hadrian's Wall or the bit that remains
to it and it was around this time of
year actually I was late October it was
fall it was it was getting dark and cold
and in England and Scotland and we
arrived right near sunset as the last of
the tour buses were leaving so we
climbed up on the wall and and pretty
much had it to ourselves which was
really cool because we've had a lot of
tourists around us and I stood up there
and the wind was blowing and the Sun was
going down and I looked off and and I
tried to imagine what it was like to be
a Roman Legionnaire a from Italy or
North Africa or the Near East who'd been
sent to this really cold place on the
edge of the world and you know who knew
what the hell was beyond there and you
were like the last outpost of what they
thought of as a civilized world and you
know they had legends and and
beliefs and they made very well that
there were there were monsters or demons
beyond there depending on where they
came from and of course well we know
that what was actually beyond there were
we're Scotsman and picks there were
picks back then but it was a profound
feeling and and many years later when I
came to write these books I it came back
to me and I said I want to do that to a
whole idea of a wall defending
civilization against unknown threats
beyond and the people who have to stand
on that wall and defend that wall
stirs something profound in me that then
and I wanted to I wanted to evoke that
of course in fantasy fantasy you you
take something real as your root but you
make it bigger and more colorful so this
is a lot bigger than Hadrian's Wall and
it's made of ice which is kind of cool
and you know actually needs some magic
in it to keep it up and all that but
it's it's an amazing thing and of course
in the world of Westeros it's one of the
one of the eighth wonders of the world
or the seven wonders of the world Lomas
long not actually then that's the nine
wonders made by man almost longest
writer so and it would be if it existed
in our world too in fact you know I was
recently in Scotland for the Edinburgh
Book Festival and they were having they
were about to have their vote on
independence whether they should secede
from the United Kingdom or not and I
suggested that if they did they should
build a giant ice wall between Scotland
and England and it would be would be an
amazing tourist attraction and you know
really help the the economy of both
countries some trouble keeping it from
melting